here we go with another one we got leela
chest zero versus stew fleas this is a
15 minute plus three second increment
game rapid game let's see what happened
crazy one that's always that's what you
get with these engines right d4 knight
f6
knight f3 and then g6 so what do you
think you're going to see next right the
c4 move usually usually you see c4 or
knight c3 wow movie you're not used to
seeing many times doesn't happen a lot
but very very cool way to transpose into
many type of
perk positions or pierce if you want to
say it correctly there right and then
also um you have some strange job of
london's that can come out of this as
well and after d5 that's exactly what we
see here is the job of london by
transposition usually the knight is not
on f3 yet but it can be which is also uh
java london is also known as the
chigorian variation putting the knight
here and bishop to f4 and d4 but in this
situation i mean this is kind of cool
i'm a fan of the job of london myself
and after bishop f4 you see the c6 move
with queen to d2 a deterrent of bishop
g7 because if you put the bishop g7
we're gonna play bishop h6 as soon as
you put the bishop on g7 maybe not all
the times a lot of times you would
castle play h4 and h5 and just literally
go for me very fun opening after queen
of d2 you see bishop to f5 and after
bishop to at5 in early knight to e5 here
now this is about 50 moves here these
games are never like super short because
they're super strong engines so after
knight to e5 this move says that i'm
going to play moves like f3 and g4 yes
f3 i know fine go tripping but f3 and g4
or e4 is is the usually the key here
especially with this knight here and
help helping us bolster g4 which helps
us get this huge king side attack knight
e5 knight after d7 saying not today you
are not about to get me with all that
craziness and f3 still happens now that
you remove the knight from f6 we can now
play e4 which is even stronger if we can
get e4 and g4 in bishop g7 didn't stop
us couldn't really stop us so we play e4
that's what we wanted to play in the
first place after e4 bishop to e6 right
then the light trade here on d7 trade
trade trade trade okay then we have this
position this is a total you know um
mix-up of the job of london and a few
other openings it feels like because
after c takes d5 we have the job of
london move that we would say here is
knight to b5 which attacks c7 if you put
well rook ca we're actually going to
take on a7 right so knight c7 is a
pretty strong move with a nice check
they're pretty annoying so black castles
and gets out the way and now right if
you look at this position what do you
actually do do you castle do you still
bring the knight to c7 and take on e6
right did we play bishop d3 maybe try to
counsel king side abandon the queen side
attack or king side attack what do you
do white to move
here it is right in fact lilith zero
says you know i like h4 you know i like
h4 come on now you know me i'm legit
zero you know i love to mate and i love
to push this h ball and up the board so
h4 absolutely h4 for the score h5 and we
live big boy stuff here so after h4
queen b6 putting a little bit of
pressure can't absolutely take it
obviously can't take it right but a6 is
going to be annoying and there's also
some queen takes d4 in there also queen
takes b2 so castle queen side really
rectifying and like stopping all of that
now this is defended and i can move my
knight if i'm kicked rook a to c8 or
he's about to get a little bit crazy
right when you castle on opposite sides
whoever gets to the king first is going
to win remember this write it down play
it back as many times as you need to
right whoever gets to the king first is
going to win so let's see what happens
rook a to c8 h5 and we live time to open
up shop big fella but we don't have
enough pieces yet to mate but it looks
good for white h5 rook c6 trying to dub
on the bub double up on the bubble up
here we're about to hit him with the
double so he says not today and this
knight is kind of crazy anyway it's done
its job let's go back here night on the
rim is them but in this case it's
defending rook after c8 whoa always play
king b1 should we play king b1 right now
g4 first g4 first says let us say zero
g4 right it's really nothing yet you
can't stop me you're not gonna sack
right here so a6 right maybe we're going
to see some b5 action maybe after moving
the queen and trying to play b4 or
something a6 c3 after queen a5 you have
to move your king or maybe like the
knight but the knight is uh
blocking this so king b1 okay
king b1 happens
we feel like we're out of the woods we
feel like everything's just fine here is
white you know we're like a moments
notice away from swinging queen h2 or
bishop h6 and taking in like maybe
until black does this move right here
rook takes c3 oh my goodness wait a
second did i just lose what just
happened
i didn't expect that
you didn't expect that rook takes c3 wow
it's on the board and now after
sacrificing the rook
well we actually sacrificed it for an
exchange so we're not put down a full
rook we're just down in exchange with
some type of attack i mean this is quite
scary so after queen takes a3 work c1 we
need to defend
at all costs knight to b6 threatening
knight a4 or sometimes c4 but we're
going to chop that boy as soon as it
gets there no knight to b6 queen to b2
trade him off please get him off the
board because there's a lot going on so
after cleaning to b2 there was queen a5
queen a5 bishop d2 defending the pawn
here and after defending of the pawn we
have rook to c6 right so there's still
some knight c4 or a4 action with rook b6
coming into play that's going to be
quite scary for you so the king moves
out of the way to a1 knight a4 and d
does happen and now what do you do about
your queen chat what do you actually do
about your queen
here it is right we actually take the
queen we pick it up and we take queen
takes b7 we don't care about none of
that
mate me if you can right what's the
movie catch me if you can right catch me
if you can queen takes b7 right and then
knight takes c3 so what do we do in this
position stop think a little bit this is
getting crazy there's made on a2 right
so watch what you do okay this knight is
pinned but are we gonna take this we're
not gonna take the brick obviously
because there's mate on a2 so what do we
do about this after knight takes c3 here
it is i hope you're ready for it here it
is one two three bam rook takes c3
that's for me and it's like wait he just
takes it back and our i mean like what
is this what did i get out of this well
hold on hold on in fact you find the
move why to move here what do you do in
this position
guys here's the move the move here is
queen to b8 check
right simple check
if rook to c8 we're gonna take that rook
and then we're gonna take the queen
and bishop to f8 right you actually have
queen to b2
to defend or actually sorry well
defending c1 but also attacking this by
a lot
by a lot no way you're getting out of
that right so okay here we go after
queen b a check there was bishop to c8
blocking
blocking the check
after the check is blocked this is a
wild position do we move the queen back
to b2
do we uh let me move the bishop up like
what do you do about this guys also
think about this bishop takes d4 is a
moment's notice away
do you take here i mean this looks kind
of murky doesn't it do you have do you
even have a move here
you even have a move
why to move what do you think do you
even have a move
of course we have a move this is leela
chad zero here it is bishop c4 for the
score i hope he was ready for that look
at this move bishop c4
blocks the connection of the defense so
you take with the rook whoa come on now
i mean this is easy like are you kidding
me
are you kidding me this is a family
channel so pawn takes so and we'll take
on ca and then make the bishop go back
to fa what's
insane
insane that this is even a move bishop
c4 what an absolute move that was sweet
queen to d8 right defending the bishop
said oh oh you really about that life
excuse me sorry sir after clean d a
bishop takes c3 and we looking great
after d takes c4 we up we totally up
right we still have the exchange but
there's still work to do queen to f4
defending the d4 pawn h6 making some
extra loofe for the king here or left if
you want to call it that h takes g h
takes g f takes g and then rook to b1
what are we saying rook to the open file
with a smile right we're going for the
pen for the win here and all that other
good stuff after rook to b1 a5 rook ba
couldn't even stop me and then after a4
i mean it just became quite simple and
quite easy now the king actually moved
out of here didn't want to be locked in
so after king b2 a3
and then instead of taking it and
allowing some counter play k to c1
stepping out of the way with queen to d7
to get off of the back right here after
queen d7 look at this beautiful move
here rook to a8 like wow rick a and it
doesn't matter if you go king 87 anyway
because queen b8 is still a move here
the intention is to put the queen on b8
right and really pin this pin and win
even if the king moves you can still do
the same thing queen b8 and the engine
even says queen f7 is even better which
is nuts so all right after rook a8 uh h5
right uh the inevitable is going to
happen it's inevitable it's going to
happen you're losing this game after h5
queen b8 and we great and we bout to go
up a piece
because wheelchairs zero is a beast king
h7 snap those and then after queen d5
first off take stock we up a full piece
a full rook but the king is a little
shaky a little scary you got to watch
out there could be some mating threats
if you act crazy here but we see she
takes h5 because we're trying to get to
this king quickly right and then queen
takes f3 and the rest is history h takes
g6 king h6 not allowing any more checks
but steps right into one after bishop d2
right always check it might be made if
you heard that before and sometimes it's
true sometimes it's not king queen check
right another check
king h7 another check
another check right e6 another check
okay that's another check
bishop six
come on now
bishop f6 this is game over guys this
one's a wrap queen takes f6 king g4
queen g5
king h3 can you find the next move
come on quickly quickly
puzzle rush
puzzle rush here it is yeah that's right
you said it that's great great job rook
h6 check and then after queen h5
mates rook takes h5 gg started a new one
that was a sweet game right sweet game a
little bit of attacking on both sides it
looked was very swash buckling lots of
uh play for both double legs black
sacked the rook in a way got the in an
exchange really got it back white was
able to keep the pressure up and go on
to win this game hopefully you enjoyed
it and if you like this one make sure
you check the next one right above me
guys so don't go anywhere click that
next video click that next one and we're
gonna see you guys on the next video
[Music]
you